at least one more U.S senator declares
their independence from the two major
parties joining Kirsten Cinema in doing
so who's it going to be here are two
very very big possibilities Joe manchin
the Manch
recently said no guarantee he stays a
Democrat up for re-election in 2024 in
West Virginia which is a state that
Trump won by 38 points so how popular is
it to be a democrat in West Virginia not
very uh so you could see Joe manchin
join Kirsten Cinema in being an
independent who else might become an
independent Lisa murkowski out of Alaska
doesn't have to face reelection for six
years might this might have been our
last race uh and if she's an independent
she gets to do what she wants gets to be
incredibly influential oh by the way
they got rid of party primaries in
Alaska and she just fended off a trump
endorsed Challenger uh and most of the
people who voted for her I'm going to
say were probably Independents or
moderates anyway including some
Democrats she and Mary paltola the
Democrat cross endorsed each other so if
you're Lisa murkowski do you really owe
the Republican Party a whole heck of a
lot at this point no so you're going to
see yet another independent U.S senator
and then if you do the math on that
depending upon who it is you could wind
up with those independent Senators being
vital to get anything done in the Senate
any uh approvals appointments uh
certainly laws though
um you know like though I'm hesitating
on that because
um uh another prediction for 2024 you're
going to see a real mess in the House of
Representatives in terms of their
ability to pass legislation you have a
republican majority of five seats but
this Republican majority does not get
along at all like you have folks like
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
over on the side just jumping up and
down and then you have some folks who
are a lot more reasonable than that so
they're gonna have a really hard time
getting any legislation across the
finish line and it's going to be up to
the Democrats whether they want to bail
them out and get them some votes on
various things it's going to be it's not
not going to be a good legislative
environment and the Republicans aren't
really into passing [ __ ] anyway
um so you know yeah so so you're going
to see some very very strange Dynamics
coming out but not a whole lot of
legislation uh because
um the the polarization unfortunately is
going to get the better of it three
independent Senators that's great and
you know what that means is that means
because it's going to be split and this
is going to be a fragmented power you'll
probably have 10 like wishy-washy
Senators if you will whether it's you
know you're gonna you're gonna wind up
with by the way there's actually some
scuttlebutt too like I think there are
some folks trying to work on some kind
of uh fulcrum in the Senate that extends
to both independent caucus maybe it's
the forward caucus who knows yeah maybe
who knows but you know there might be a
couple of card carrying Independents in
there gonna be wild you're gonna be a
great year happy 2023 everyone may it be
the best year yet
[Music]
foreign